who can i get who can i who can i get on
the show
who can bridge not only
the cheesehead nation but with raider
nation who can i get
that is not only somebody you can bridge
those two but talk
about professional football
i'm mandated to talk in this voice when
i hear this music
great you do a great professional
football going into the pro football
hall of fame this weekend i can say it
he can't
because he will hear his name reach the
levels of immortality
this weekend and he's also somebody
who is a heisman trophy winner from the
greatest
institution of higher learning in all of
planet earth
i say blue know it to charles woodson
how are you charles blue noise
man how's that for an introduction
charles hi man that was hey that was a
great voice
that that was that was fantastic i i
wouldn't want to come out man to
anything other than what you just did so
that means every time i'm on the show
you've got to replicate that i have set
the bar high but i am willing to
raise it even further sir i am so
excited for you
this weekend charles i'm so excited how
are you feeling what are you
what's your energy like right now
charles
i mean my my energy is good man you know
uh
you know i i think once you you enter
into the realm of you know being a you
know hall of fame finalists i mean you
get to a certain point and then at that
point
um you know just out of your hands i i
did all that
i did all that i could do as a player
you know what i'm saying to get to this
moment that's
that's my my job and then it's the job
of the voters man to vote me in so
i mean i feel good you know uh i'm ready
for the weekend to get here and
you know see what happens so we'll see
how it goes what are you gonna do
saturday
who are you gonna surround yourself with
on saturday that's the day
so who are you going to be with what's
your plan right now
uh what the plan is man i'll be around
uh
some family of course you know my wife
um
kids of course and then we're just gonna
um you know keep our ears open man the
eyes open
you gotta stop this thing goes man you
got a special bottle of wine picked out
you got something like that you got a
couple of them what do you got got a
couple of them walk me through i got i
got
i got some intercept cap okay you know
yep i'll probably start off you know
we'll probably start off with the white
wine because i have a chardonnay as well
okay so you always start off with the
white sure
and then you ease into it to a lighter
body wine so we'll go with the
intercepto
and then we'll move into a you know a
blend you know we got the red blend so
we'll go
intercept red blend and then the booming
boom
where's the kaboom big boy where's the
kaboom yes then we go we step to the big
boy we go to the cabernet
uh and then you know what now i have the
woodson bourbon whiskey so then it's
kind of like my
my after hours drink you know so i got
the wood some bourbon whiskey that i'll
go to after the cab man so i got a full
lineup
i'm ready now uh for some reason uh my
colleague chris brockman
um upon hearing that there is now
woodson whiskey
at woodsonwhiskey.com you would like
some of that stuff is what you're doing
i just think it's fair that we get to
sample and just you know well
mcconaughey
gave us some of his whiskey that we
display here we don't drink it
everyone has their own whiskey come
bring some by and we put it on display
those homes so it's available charles
well you know i i didn't know that
everybody on the set drinks but now that
i know that
please we're total degenerates you've
been here hey
yeah hey rich you're always you're
always on the list
so just you know just keep you keep your
eye out okay no look for the mail man
[Laughter]
eyes peeled charles you will get you
will get yours
okay uh eyes my head's on a swivel when
it comes to your
fantastic juice it's amazing and it it
really is i'm not just saying that
because you're on here
it really is terrific and and uh that's
part of the
let's uh let's mention this here the
super bowl culinary kickoff that you do
every single
year what and that's one of my favorite
events to go to in person but what
what's the plan for that this year
for the super bowl charles
yeah well you know everything is you
know a little bit different than you
this year
uh but we still are gonna do some uh
some stuff surrounding
you know super bowl that weekend um
some of it will be virtual you know and
so
you know we're just trying to acclimate
to you know how things are this year
and so we'll we'll still do it you know
still raise money for a great cause
um but it'll be considerably you know
smaller
yes of course than it was in previous
years so
uh but we're still forging ahead man
culinarykickoff.com
uh saturday february 6th it's uh going
to be taking
uh place virtually nine to eight to nine
eastern time
uh go to culinary kickoff.com to learn
more and hopefully there'll be something
well not hopefully there will be
something to celebrate on saturday night
um charles woodson if i had told you
if i had told you let's say back in the
day let's say
when you were first drafted by the
raiders that
um you would be and just hear me out
here that
you would be going into the pro football
hall of fame
announced the night before tom brady
plays in his 10th career super bowl at
the age of 43.
you would have said what you would have
said what to me charles
uh first i probably would have said uh
when 2021 yep wow
yeah i i couldn't imagine that either of
us you know would have still been
playing
in 2021 so i would have said you know
what what
that's a hell of a dream that you have
there rich you know whatever was going
to happen
would have happened years ago and not in
2021 right
um but this is this is you know for me i
sit back and i've watched you know uh
brady the last you know a couple of
weeks
you know playing in the playoffs and
it's just amazing to me man and i know
everybody's talked about it but
the fact that this man has been the 10
super bowls half of his career
you know myself playing in the nfl for a
long time knowing how hard it is to get
to
just to get to the playoffs let alone to
make it to the super bowl
to get there 10 times man is
unbelievable
um so i i the hall of fame part of your
question
i would say yeah i could see that i
could see me being introduced
but tom brady still playing and in his
10th super bowl
absolutely not it's truly unheard of and
i'm sure you know again you you have
um all sorts of emotions what was it
like watching the nfc championship game
with one of your former teams that you
hold so near and dear to you
uh with the packers in cheesehead nation
needing
so much needing to win that one so much
i mean
i use the word need purposefully here
because of how long it has been
since you went out in that super bowl
with uh
with an injury that that that eventually
was the winner anyway because you said
as long as obama was gonna be rooting
for the bears we need to show
up in his house which was one of the
greatest
lines in the history of locker room
celebrations um
what was it like for you to watch that
game with brady versus rogers and the
packers
charles well man i was i was pulling for
you know pulling for the packers man
heavily man because
um you know earlier in the season you
know kind of
you know once they got past the midway
point i thought that man the packers
looked like the team to beat to me and
you know to run to the super bowl and so
i really felt like they had started to
click at the right time
and i thought that this was going to be
the year that you know aaron rodgers
would
you know lead his team to a second super
bowl
and then you know as the you know the
playoffs you know
roll around and the tampa bay buccaneers
started to play better i thought to
myself
you know once they drew them you know to
go to the championship game i said man
this is this is probably
the least of the matchups that the
packers want and
the reason being is because you know
tampa bay handled them pretty handily
you know earlier in that season and the
way they beat them
was with defense and being able to run
the ball
and you see the way that this game
played out that's exactly kind of what
happened
you know tampa bay came in beat him with
defense
jumped on him early um and then you know
the run by fournette you know running
the ball and that touchdown he ran was
incredible
uh but i still thought that you know
during the course of that game that
a-rod would be able to you know put the
team on his back so to speak they came
up with some big second half turnovers
um that greenback wasn't really able to
capitalize on which i think
you know killed him as far as the
outcome of the game but i really thought
this was going to be the year
you know that they got back to the super
bowl man so i was
i was hurting man especially with the
last series of the game for the packers
and you know
uh fourth down deciding to go for the
field goal and not having a chance
for a-rod to score that touchdown and it
was just hard man it was hard to watch
you know for for the packers and for
aaron rodgers and all the guys on that
team
coastal floor um but then again you know
what i mean
i i do have an old teammate on the team
the other side of the ball
you know brady and it's like i'm happy
for him because man this dude is
legendary and he's doing something
nobody's ever done before taking a team
uh to the super bowl in their own you
know hometown
like who who better to do it you know
than tom brady so
you know definitely torn you know about
the outcome
um more so for the packers because i
thought this was going to be their year
but definitely happy for for tom and his
team and for being able to get there
well charles what's in it it was obvious
that aaron rodgers thought the same
thing as you did that this was the year
he thought that this was the year this
was the team this was the moment
and then it didn't happen and then the
moment where the game could be in his
hands to save
um the coach says let's kick a field
goal
and then his post game comments were
quite emotional i'll put you on the spot
you're used to it anyway
what do you think's going on in aaron's
mind what what do you think is happening
between those very famous temples of his
with his future charles
well i think there's you know two things
that play i think there's the emotion of
the game
you know um you're coming off of a
an nfc championship game this is the you
know game before the super bowl you feel
good you're loose you feel like you're
going to win it
and then all of a sudden you know it
ends the way that it did so
you know the emotions are running high
and uh
you know he's noticing you know of
course he's obviously pissed off
you know about the outcome and then i
think you know of course his mind
swirling around the fact that
you know they did take a quarterback you
know in the first round and you know
he's 30
you know i think 36 35 years old or
whatever he is
and so at the end of your career you
know no matter who you are
you do start thinking about the end you
know whether you're
playing for your same team and retire or
you're you know
released and or traded to another team
those are
realistic things that are going through
his mind so i'm sure at that time
um with all of the emotions swirling
around the game
and then also going back to the fact
that they you know drafted a quarterback
in the first round
all of his emotions got intertwined at
once
and so that's kind of what came out his
mouth but for me
you know there's no way that i see him
you know playing in
at least next year he's not going to be
playing anywhere else
next year other than green bay but i
think in his mind
he does see that look i got you know
probably four or five more years
um who knows what they're going to do
with you know the immediate future of
this team
but i just don't see him going anywhere
next year well the way i sussed it out
is just like you charles
um that it was emotional like anybody
who's listening to this conversation
right now
imagine you put your heart and soul in
your job
and then your boss uh says at the very
biggest moment we're gonna we're gonna
let
uh another employee handle this at the
moment and hope to you have another shot
right
and then then you get put in front of a
nationally televised press conference
that
you know emotions are raw but the fact
that he brought it up
in the way that he did after the season
in which he had
um an mvp campaign saying you know
that he had uh he was at peace with
everything made it seem like
he really wasn't at peace about all this
and that 2021 clearly mark murphy has
come out and said you know we'd
we'd be stupid and brian gunakun said
today
that that rogers they have many more
years of success with him
but it's still there man i mean there's
no doubt that it is still there
do you think he's going to finish his
career
in green bay charles woodson
uh well i i kind of see him you know
along the same lines as um you know tom
brady i think these guys think that they
could play forever
you know brady's proven that you can
play at 43 be successful make it to a
super bowl
i think rogers is probably in that same
realm as far as you know saying hey i
could i can play at least
you know six more years you know um
so in that sense if his career does
extend that long
he'll be playing for somebody else by
the end of that but in the immediate
um you know next you know couple two
three years
they're going to give them some more
money somehow you know to keep them
happy
um and they're going to try to you know
do some things as far as
you know the franchise maybe maybe
involve him a little more
as far as you know who they're bringing
in who they're looking at
and kind of give him you know some say
so as far as
you know who's on that team who they're
looking at free agent why
you know um to make him happy because
look he's the best man for the job in
green bay there's no question about that
um if he was to be gone let's say if he
was to be gone next year
green bay uh wisconsin and you know
packers fans around the whole world
would
you you want to talk about you know a
fan base that would
not be going forward not be happy about
something
you let that happen you know so i think
he'll be there for you know for the
foreseeable future but if
this career extends as long as i'm sure
he wants to
then he'll be playing for somebody else
before i let you go charles woodson how
do you see
super bowl 55 playing out who wins
yeah for me yeah so it's such a such a
great matchup man just
you know you got the young brilliance
you know of my homes and that offense
with kelsey and hill man you know
they're they're
virtually unstoppable um but i see uh i
see a tampa bay offense that can be
equally as unstoppable if they're
clicking i think it's going to come down
to
tampa if tampa bay is to win this game
then they have to do a great job of
eliminating big plays
they have to be able to get off of the
field on third down that's going to be
huge this week
not allowing uh kansas city to extend
drives
and they got to make them go to long the
long haul you know it can't be quick
scores because we know how quickly they
can score
and then they got to take advantage of
tampa bay does on offense of their
opportunities and they got to
put points on the board because we know
kansas city
and how quickly you know they can score
so
um for me i'm gonna
i think we're gonna take the the vegas
approach rich okay and i think that uh
i think tampa bay is getting three and a
half
um i'm gonna take tampa bay with the
three and a half oh boy look at him
going all must burger on us over here
be honest with you man there's really no
reason when you look at the two teams
there's no reason to pick against kansas
city there really there really is
i mean they that they're they're an
unbelievable
unbelievable team um so i i could i
could
give you all the reasons you know how
tampa bay could win but
it's another thing to go out there and
actually do it so i'm going to go with
the vegas approach
charles how do we feel about that total
how do you feel about that total look at
you man
say it again how do you feel about the
total 56 and a half
56 and a half look at you guys yeah
yeah i can see it getting up there man
okay as an nfl person i do not condone
this conversation whatsoever
hey charles wouldn't it be something
wouldn't it be something charles if
games online brady fades back and a
michigan man
like say frank clark comes around the
end and hits him as he throws and it's
called a fumble wouldn't that be
something
if something like that happens charles
what do you think you mean
you mean the way that brandon graham did
in a couple super bowls how about that
it's
and and has that ever happened before
even brandon graham
happened has that ever happened before
with it but luckily man
well not luckily luck wasn't on my side
you know
i i liked my little frank sinatra and i
wanted luck to be a lady tonight man but
it didn't work out for me
what do you call that game chris is a
big patriot fan what do you call that
game
call it in new england with all due
respect charles that's called the snow
game he calls it the snow game charles
what do you think what do you think of
patriots fans calling that game the snow
game charles
there's probably a lot of other
adjectives that i could give to the
naming of that game
and it rhymes with time i know you run a
family show
i'll keep those comments to myself
certainly certainly since it rhymes with
tuck all right charles thank you very
much
absolutely thanks for the call uh
cwintercepswine.com
for his terrific juice
woodsonwhiskey.com for his new whiskey
and then
kickoff.com to learn more about the
fundraising and the great event that's
happening super bowl week thanks for the
call charles and
uh good luck in advance and i look
forward to celebrating uh with a text of
some sort
this weekend absolutely man i'll let you
know what i know
okay you got it that's charles woodson
everybody here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here